Allora innanzitutto piglia questo eh
questa parte è complessa bisogna
posizionarsi sopra il tavolino darsi un
colpetto leggerissimo sotto il chapet e
agganciarsi subito alla roccia di sopra
Ok
è fino a qua ci si tira su piano perché
sennò si scivola perfetto Tutto ok e
facciamo la stessa cosa con la roccia di
sopra
perfetto una volta arrivati qua
attenzione che qua è difficile bisogna
mettersi sopra questo punto piano molto
piano e cercare di tirarsi molto piano
sopra questa roccia qua molto piano
perché si scivola
Una volta fatto questo bisogna fare
piano anche quella successiva che non è
così faceva attenzione eh colpettino per
ingannare il gioco Ci vuole sempre non
t'ho lasciato ingannare dai pipistrelli
che compariranno tra poco